[Music]
thank you
I want to put her in the mood watch a
horror movie yeah she's like twice our
age I really don't think it's gonna
happen
she's here
you are breathtaking thank you now don't
stay up and watch scary movies okay
it'll give you nightmares again
so what do you want to do
[Music]
you like can you just leave me alone
such a jerk don't hang up
what was that
God
there's someone there
Ashley
are you hiding
I'll find you Mario protected you
[Music]
this is exciting
[Music]
tis the season
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
what are you doing man please let me out
of this you're home alone again
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
why can't X's just go away
good night blah
blah Steven Spielberg presents Gremlins
Billy Pelzer has a nice home
Billy is that you yeah Mom it's me a
nice job
[Music]
a nice girl if you're not doing anything
this Thursday night maybe you'd like to
go out on a date with me I'd love to and
loving parents who are about to give you
you're gonna like this no no don't shake
it we're gonna have to open it now it
won't wait till Christmas the most
unusual gift he ever got what is it no
it's your new pet
come on Bonnie be a good dog my dad gave
it to me
but there are a few things to keep in
mind
if you expose it to the light you may
heard it if you get it wet
it will multiply all that from water it
got wet yeah plain water and most
important no matter how much they bake
never never let them eat after midnight
because when they do
they
become clever
mischievous
come on here
I'm dangerous
monsters right
I don't know well I don't know maybe
thousands
of things where do they come look I know
it sounds crazy I know but in a few
hours you're gonna have a major disaster
on your hands
they'll be expecting you
foreign
[Music]
the grown-ups
thank you
and the kids
Christmas evil
the non-believers
and the Screamers
[Music]
and this Christmas you better believe in
Santa or he'll slay you
Christmas evil the night he dropped in
if you leave now you're gonna blow with
her forever come on come on come on go
talk to her there's about choices man
and one bad one can ruin every good one
you ever made all right
Emily it's freezing out here why don't I
just give you a ride home that would be
great thank you
it's gonna be a good night bro
so we're gonna be this what's good with
getting food it's after midnight oh it's
fine
it's fine I need seven in etm by the way
dude you're killing me right now
I'm sorry about him
all set
let's go
the hell is that
probably wouldn't use ATM but why didn't
he come in then who cares I'm freezing
let's go just wait a second
he's just watching us
you know
it's just something I can help you with
all 9-1-1 I heard my phone where's your
phone
are you okay
the sun will be up for hours we'll be
lucky if we don't freeze today
there's no heat pick up the power
I don't know maybe we did something to
him he's one guy
and there's three of us
[Applause]
we locked in
so
how would you feel about going to the
Mounds for Christmas with Grace she
really wants to get to know you guys
that's our mom's hat
you okay
I don't want to leave you here with the
kids if you're not feeling I'm feeling
fine it was my idea and it's a couple
days I can do a couple days okay guys
I'm off
have fun
what is that
it's crazy
all committed suicide
repent and you will find Salvation
guys
things are very
uncomfortable between us and we're stuck
in a house together
[Music]
the power's out
where are my things
that makes no sense
what I heard something
repent
elevate your sins
[Music]
hello
did you do that you didn't do anything
[Applause]
we're leaving what are you talking about
look outside we're stuck here
please help me
[Music]
it's okay
trust me
you have nothing to be scared about
foreign
[Music]
looks like Martha Stewart threw up in
here this is delicious honey a little
dry Well mine's delicious mine's dry do
you want to trade it's Christmas it's
Christmas it's Christmas
with those holiday greetings
how we were going to survive Christmas
with 12 people stuck in a house with no
heat and no electricity or food there's
plenty of leftovers Howard
beer it is
weirdest thing there's no cars no people
how long can this keep up
we heard something on the roof
the hell's this
Saint Nicholas is not coming this year
instead a much darker ancient Spirit
those are Hooves elk or a goat kind of
goat walks on its hind legs
his name is Krampus
thank you
he and his helpers did not come to give
but to take
dreams
everybody hold on to each other
[Applause]
he is the shadow of Saint Nicholas
[Music]
it's Christmas nothing bad's gonna
happen on Christmas
[Music]
got something for me
[Music]
type of Christmas it ain't all candy
canes and pretty lights
I heard this story this fella
dressed as Santa he said about killing
them that was naughty creep
every year
a new town everyone knows that story
it's an urban legend
Christmas the number one holiday for
people going nuts
listen we've got a lead on our killer
from the motel
hiding in praying sight
what if he was
first we're just gonna have to take this
Maniac down ourselves
Christmas Eve is the scariest damn night
of the year
foreign
Bakery one woman is about to confront
her past
[Music]
[Applause]
unforgivable act of violence It also
says here that after they fried him in
the chair they cremated him and sent his
Ashes to his mother in coosburg
something else was just left at the back
porch too must be that gingerbread
seasoning
an Unholy curse
what is it I think I know what I mean
who it is
a new kind of cookie
what the hell is that what sharing the
Pillsbury Doughboy
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
you
run run as fast as you can something's
in the oven the ginger dead man evil
evil good
eat me you [ __ ]
15 years ago on Christmas Eve
his family
became his victims
foreign
friends that sucks everyone should be
home for Christmas are about to discover
Lauren we're open house present s why
don't you open the present we
want their house
who is in my house tonight don't you
have lots of toys to deliver to good
little boys and girls
it really shouldn't provoke somebody
like and on December 25th you're
definitely getting punked
all he wants for Christmas
is Megan in her room
is a new family he can treat like his
very own
[Music]
oh
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
it's my privilege to teach you this
semester enjoy your winter breaks and
Merry Christmas what's up ladies excited
for tonight it is our last day of our
last fall semester of college ever
[Music]
can you take a photo of all of us of
course where's Helena
she was pounding Baca sodas earlier but
she looked really good cheese
shouldn't have let her go back by
herself she's fine come on live a little
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Helena hasn't gotten home yet if I were
missing I'd want you to unleash The
Bloodhounds and track me down
she was at dko last night
system creating problems huh right hello
hello
[Music]
break could just be a delay of some sort
snow my friend is missing nine times out
of ten the girl's just with a boyfriend
I will bring you
to your niece
foreign
[Music]
I'm tired of hiding
I'm tired of running
he messed with the wrong sisters
one cold night
science and evil Collide
oh yeah
foreign
let alone a human cell this is a
disaster look I just saw something that
doesn't belong in this world and it's
out there killing my friends now tell me
what it is
Jack Frost
[Music]
living full-blooded a whole new meaning
hey Jack what you left the 710 split
[Applause]
hell has just frozen over
[Applause]
blow me
[Music]
[Music]
Jack Frost
[Music]
thank you